nos piden que resolvamos la ecuación
menos 3x cuadrada más 10 x 30 y hay
varias formas de resolver esto sin
embargo yo quiero resolverlo y centrarme
en encontrar las raíces por medio de la
fórmula cuadrática así que déjame
escribir la que otra vez menos 3x
cuadrada más 10 x menos 3 igual a cero y
darte cuenta que ya está en su forma
estándar y quiere resuelve esta ecuación
dos veces para que te des cuenta que
usando la fórmula cuadrática no importa
con manipulemos esta ecuación nos van a
dar las mismas raíces los mismos
resultados y bueno ya que tenemos aquí
la ecuación cuanto vale a b y c y para
esto sería muy bueno recordar que es lo
que nos dice la fórmula cuadrática y la
fórmula cuadrática nos dice lo siguiente
si tenemos ecuaciones de la forma
estándar a x cuadrada más bx más e igual
a cero entonces las raíces de esta
ecuación son igual a menos b más menos
la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 4
hace todo esto sobre 2
ya que está la fórmula cuadrática que
hemos derivado de esta ecuación
cuadrática que tenemos aquí lo cual lo
hemos visto en varios vídeos pasados y
hablando de recuerda que la fórmula
cuadrática tiene dos posibles soluciones
una tomando el signo positivo y otra
tomando el signo negativo pero bueno
regresemos a esta ecuación cuanto vale a
b y c como ya está en forma estándar
sabemos que a vale igual a menos 3 b va
a valer igual a 10 y se va a valer menos
3 y bueno una vez que ya tenemos a b y c
entonces podemos solucionar esta
ecuación cuadrática utilizando la
fórmula cuadrática que dice menos 20 es
decir menos 10 más menos la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada pero b vale 10 10
al cuadrado es 100 menos 4 veces hace
menos 4 x menos 3 x menos 3 mejor
déjenme escribirlo para que quede todo
bastante claro me va a quedar menos 4 x
menos 3 x menos 3 la raíz cuadrada de
todo esto y después a todo lo que
tenemos aquí arriba hay que dividirlo
entre dos veces aunque es 2 x menos 3
entonces que me quedan menos 10 más
menos la raíz cuadrada de 100 menos y
aquí tengo menos 3 x menos 3 lo cual me
da 9 positivo 9 positivo por 4 36 si
este menos se queda en menos menos 36 y
todo esto dividido entre menos 6 y 100
en los 36 64 por lo tanto me queda menos
10 más menos la raíz cuadrada de 64
entre menos 6 064 tiene raíz cuadrada
exacta su raíz principal es 8 y se quitó
más menos me queda menos 10 más menos 8
entre menos 6 y entonces esto es lo que
vale x y esto me da pie a que yo pueda
escribir mis dos raíces mi primera
versión de estas raíces es tomando el
signo positivo me queda menos 10 más 8
que es menos 2 entre menos 6 esto cuando
tomamos el signo positivo y es igual a
un tercio menos entre menos me da más y
dos sextos es un tercio y después si
tomamos la versión negativa entonces me
queda que x es igual a menos 10 menos 8
lugar me da menos 18 entre menos 6 y
esto es igual a 3 positivo menos entre
menos me da más
18 en 36 me da tres esta es mi segunda
raíz cuando tomo el signo negativo
entonces estoy diciendo que las raíces
son un tercio y tres de esta ecuación
cuadrática con la que empezamos ahora lo
que quiero que veamos a continuación
es como si manipulamos esta ecuación
cuadrática vamos a llegar a las mismas
raíces porque hay personas que podrían
pasar todo esto del otro lado de la
ecuación o dicho de otra manera
cambiarle de signo a todo lo que está en
esta ecuación y decidir que no vamos a
llegar a lo mismo así que vamos a
hacerlo me quedaría 3x cuadrada menos 10
x más 3 igual a 0 lo único que estoy
haciendo es multiplicando todo x menos 1
y entonces en esta ocasión me queda que
avale 3 b vale menos 10 y se vale 3 y
pues vamos a aplicar otra vez la fórmula
general para ver si llegamos a las
mismas raíces y me queda 10 más menos la
raíz cuadrada de menos 10 al cuadrado
pero esto es sí
- 10 al cuadrado 100 menos 4 por 3 que
es 12 por 3 que es 36 12 por 3 36 y todo
esto dividido entre dos veces a es decir
6 y cuantos esto no quedaría 10 + menos
la raíz cuadrada de 64 otra vez 100
menos 36 es lo mismo que 64 por lo tanto
la raíz es 8 y esto dividido entre 6 y
vamos a calcular las raíces otra vez 10
más 8 entre 6 es lo mismo que 3 o en su
dado caso 10 menos 8 entre 6 es lo mismo
que dos sextos que por cierto habíamos
visto que es lo mismo que un tercio y
aquí está llegamos a lo mismo es decir
que obtenemos las mismas raíces cuando
manipulamos la ecuación